hey youtubers its charlie this is gonna
be my non-spoilery Civil War review I'm
going to go ahead and assume that you
know spider-man is in the film just
because he's been in so much of the
marketing materials so there are a few
minor assumptions that you probably know
about the film I don't know if I call it
my favorite Marvel film now it's
definitely tied for first with Winter
Soldier if it's not my favorite it's
probably gonna take a couple more
viewings before I decide it definitely
falls into the trap where you have all
these characters and even though they do
an amazing job of using all them in
really interesting ways there's all
kinds of crazy Easter eggs that we could
talk about in my Easter Egg video you
can get a little distracted from what
the main purpose of the movie is and
really the movie is about three
characters and they had a whole bunch of
other stuff that they had to do in it
like set up Black Panthers character
introduced the spider-man character so
let's talk about the performances first
it's always amazing to watch Robert
Downey jr. when he goes on a tear
because even when he was a child actor
like if you go back and watch his films
from the 80s you can see that he's
amazing and even though I think he's a
better actor than Chris Evans I think
Chris Evans performance as Captain
America is way better in this film he
definitely has the best performance but
his name is on the film so it makes
sense that he would have to bring the
heat so whatever you've heard the vast
majority this revolves around his
character the trick of the movie
reminded me a little bit of a community
episode which is interesting I'll talk a
little bit more about it in Easter eggs
but the Russos directed an episode of
community they did the Dungeons &
Dragons episode which is one of the best
episodes of any television show ever so
you can go back and watch that and
understand why they're so good with
these characters I've heard a couple
different people call this film an
apology like Marvel's apology for
Avengers age of Ultron I don't think
that's totally fair there is a lot of
good stuff in Avengers age of Ultron but
I think that Civil War does a better job
developing its villain character it also
does a much better job with the black
widow character I think all the best
Black Widow scenes in any Marvel movie
are from both of the Russos movies which
is Winter Soldier and now Civil War so
if you really like Scarlett Johansson
black widows character she really shines
in this film black panther we got to
talk about him though chadwick boseman
was awesome I cannot wait to see the
Black Panther movie after this I think I
said it before but his character started
out as something of a stereotype so
there were so many things that could
have gone wrong about this character in
the movie but they totally pull it off
he comes away seeming like the biggest
badass you've seen in a long time
bigger badass
invision who has the mind gem who's
probably the most powerful person on
earth next to dr. strange or maybe
Scarlet Witch but we haven't even got
the Doctor Strange movie yet so we can't
really talk about him I actually was not
as big a fan of Scarlet Witch envisioned
the movie as I thought I was gonna be
they did a really good job of using them
as a MacGuffin in the film but the
MacGuffin isn't like the ultimate thing
that you're working towards so they kind
of get shoved to the side a little the
logic gets swept under the rug a little
bit that was what you know one of the
weak points of the film if you really
want to nitpick there were a couple
logic flaws but if you understand the
purpose of the movie you understand why
they made certain story decisions to
push characters in a certain direction
we'll talk more about that during Easter
eggs but it was to the film's benefit
that most of these other Avengers
characters were just background players
spider-man though when you go see the
movie you will totally understand why it
was so important for him to be in this
movie and it has absolutely nothing to
do with his special powers or his
abilities it's all about the tone
spider-man balances the tone of the film
in the perfect way it is pure comic-book
spider-man you will be so excited for
the spider-man movie after you go see
this in the female characters I'm so
excited about Aunt May she definitely
feels in the vein of a Pepper Potts type
character someone who's smarter than
they pretend to be so I think that's
gonna be really exciting for the
spider-man film but we can talk about
that when I post my spoiler video and
what about all these other things that
it was doing to set up other movies this
is technically the first phase three
film in a lot of the biggest sins
committed by one of the worst Marvel
films Iron Man 2 was that it got bogged
down trying to set up all the other
phase 1 stuff that was going on so again
they did a really good job of leaving
things letting you know where everything
is headed you have a clear idea of where
all the characters stand what the
relationships are between them and what
might be happening the next time they
show up but just to be clear with the
movie order the next movie is going to
be Doctor Strange this fall so we'll
meet him for the first time that'll be
like ant-man's film it's really weird so
they'll keep it relatively
self-contained till he's established
then kind of weave him in with a larger
universe then the next movie is going to
be spider-man homecoming they're still
locking down characters villains
I'll talk all about it during my
spoilery Easter Egg video so be sure to
subscribe to get that and I am doing a
giveaway it's a gift certificate for two
imax
tickets which is like a fifth
dollar value all you have to do to enter
that is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on this video we can spend all
day talking about Easter eggs and
character relationships really like the
character relationships that I'm most
excited for after this like the
character dynamics are like the
spider-man family unit you have Peter
Parker Aunt May and then you have Tony I
have a whole bunch of ideas about where
they're taking those three people just
based on what happens in the movie can't
really talk about it till we get to
spoilers cap and Bucky totally loved
their scenes together and the other two
characters kind of like the relationship
between them I can't talk about because
it's kind of spoilery so I'll talk about
a little during my easter egg video
because the movie does a really good job
of pacing itself setting things up in a
really clear logical way like you know
like I said the villain Daniel Bruhl
they're a couple really cool things that
that character keeps going back to and
it serves as his character development
it helps frame him in the universe gives
context for why he's doing what he's
doing his relationship with the other
characters is gonna be really
interesting too because Daniel Bruhl is
just an amazing actor so really
everything in this movie just got pulled
off so well that it is like the new
benchmark for Avengers films technically
it's a Captain America film but it's
really like Avengers 2.5 because there
are so many of them in it so let me know
in the comments what your favorite part
about the film and please use spoiler
tags if you want to be really specific
but I almost forgot to say like the
whole logic for the Civil War the reason
why everybody's finding each other they
actually provide compelling reasons for
why each character makes the decision
that they make but what's gonna happen
next is I'm gonna post my Easter Egg
video so that should come pretty soon
well you guys wait for me to post that
you can click here to learn more about
what's going on with the spider-man film
and you can click here to start getting
ready for a game of Thrones this weekend
thank you so much watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight
you